well I'm gonna give her a shout shout
out to my buddy Carter he's out in
Arkansas and he he hit me up one day and
asked me if I knew who you were because
he's like I love his podcasts he said
he's up he's the guy who started a
kinase array he's actually a radio DJ
who started doing comedy he loves his
podcast because he gets insight into
different perspectives on comedy mm-hmm
so I think that's why she listens you
can listen different people when I see
I've seen who you've had in the show and
you've had different people who have had
success in multiple aspects to get that
kind of like their perspective so and
now it might be back in like a hundred
episodes or so so yeah right I have
these I have notebooks now I'm selling
notebooks okay and Carter actually
bought one and filmed and unboxing up oh
nice put it on YouTube look that's cool
I was like showing my wife I was like
hey honey we made it with my face on
[Music]
you
yeah this is volunteers there are local
spring water okay they do custom labels
they hooked up read the verse with
labels that's cool
and now listeners can go on hop breath
podcast.com and get them that's awesome
we're merchandising nice well growing
here Joe it's not exciting that's pretty
cool it's been a while since we've done
this so let's eat would you are you good
with that yeah yeah yeah it's a fancy
looking microphone yes it's the same
ones we've been using since day one okay
cool so let's let's get them into it
here you ready to do this man do it
are you excited yeah how you doing good
good good Zee again yeah hot breath
averse welcome back to the ER let's take
two on that should we take two I hate to
take two but we're gonna leave it all in
all right because this is a one-man band
I'm not gonna edit hot breath averse
welcome back to the hot breath podcast
through a weekly guide to comedy mastery
I am Joel buyers today we have a master
of show production hot brethren and
sistren this gentleman has been working
for 10 years honing the craft of
developing a show that actually can be a
tour he's done seminars with these he is
the blueprint for how you can produce
successful shows he's actually a
previous guest as well back in hot
paratha so number 35 that'll be linked
in the show notes for you to check out
if you want to hear his first interview
but this episode is all about the DIY
approach to making your comedy a
business he started out just hustling
through yoga studios and moose lodges
and now he has developed his system into
an actual production company called one
up comedy straight out of the ATL Joe
Pettis welcome to the hot breath of
Earth thank you for having me back
I'm so excited hot hot breath averse I
like that yes a lots changed yeah we did
this we did the first one in your in my
living room in the livery of your
apartment now you have a home yeah yeah
you have a car of a car yeah you're a
grown up I'm yeah finally well I was a
grown up much one mid 20s and nest I do
stand-up comedy and gave it all up right
yeah you got now I'm back on track like
I couldn't get into grad school so I'm
gonna do comedy exactly yeah
and it's paid off man yeah and then
looking back on our first interview and
now researching you and what you've done
since then it is impressive to think
about what you've accomplished but you
started your first show in 2009 it is
now 2019 yeah so this is a 10-year
journey that I think comedians need to
understand is that you failed a lot of
shows before you figured out what worked
so starting from the beginning what do
you look for when you're approaching a
venue about a show uh well these days I
would say all the venues I produced
shows it are you know yeah all up in you
there are venues that one way or another
have actually approached me interesting
okay example we heard the Highland in
the way this started was Jo Neil Smith
was doing shows here and she approached
me as a hey would you be interested in
doing shows there as well I wasn't sure
I'd like to try it out and then as I
started I kept doing it I started
forming a better relationship everyone
involved here and that's kind of like
what I found is though the places that
work are places that want you to be
there hmm you know the last I'd say four
or five years mmm pretty much every
venue I've done a show it had been
placed it one way or another has sought
me out like non-si sought me out but was
seeking to do comedy and then maybe
someone else made that connection like
this guy this comedy shows I'm no longer
doing like the cold calling showing up
to venues saying hey do you want to do
like do you want to do a show whatever
so even my first show back to 9 that was
not the owner of five to nine saying hey
we will wear a new venue we like to do
comedy so from my experience my best
shows I've been in places that just want
to do comedy in general yeah in like
this your Sweetwater show yeah that it
was the first brewery comedy show which
is now like a template for people to
start comedy shows the first breweries
show in the country but it was a tweet
that exactly kind of started that now
eight years doing it and it's one of the
dopest shows in the country right so
would you recommend
comedians looking to start a show is the
cold calling approach a good way to get
your your feet wet or is it too
like maybe wait till a show comes to you
almost um I guess depends I'm glad I
think I did it helped for me early on
doing like this shown up to venues and
see if they'd be interested in Comi I
got my foot in the door and then it kind
of helped me learn the ins and ins outs
of like producing a comedy show so maybe
so I would say in some ways it's nice to
kind of go in a place where you're not
is invested and then maybe fail there
right that later on in your career you
can do better somewhere else and what
would you say to these venues when
you're approaching them different things
basically hey what you interested like I
just I still I take the bite I still do
it somewhat like now I'm now I'm living
up in North Georgia I have started
approaching other videos up there but
none of them have reached back out to me
so so it's kind of like disheartening to
be like okay I have a lot of successful
shows but I still can't get my foot in
the door some other places but for why
would usually do just you know give an
example why I've done okay I've had
success I say I had more success now
that's how I approach like venues if I'm
trying to go like farther out like I
recently earlier this year I did a show
in my hometown st. Mary's where I did
like the st. like a little community
theater they did there hmm and I sold
him like hey I produce see successful
shows and Lana I'm originally from there
I think I could do well so guys it's a
party like similar to like getting
booked to the comedy clubs I'm like that
you can't have this pitch of who you are
and what you're doing given previous
examples of success and you are you
looking for venues when you do cold call
venues are you looking for venues that
are already doing like live events like
music or karaoke or something has to
help a little bit yeah I think mostly
yeah I've been doing these days like
approaching kind of like private event
venues kind of Highland in for the
longest time was like a private event
but still is they do like weddings and
stuff here
it wasn't like your traditional we do
music every night or karaoke every night
those I think if Pied helps to start
finding those type of places because
they already have if I have the
infrastructure they have I guess maybe
have a stage or sound system less things
you have to be involved with yourself my
main thing nowadays is I try I find my a
thing is I try find places that don't
serve food that's my interest yeah I
prefer venues that don't aren't like I
do do some shows at our restaurants and
stuff I prefer this
trying to stay away from necks I feel
like the more other variables you have
involved that more take so it takes away
from the comedy you know so I can't
laugh some people like ordering food or
stuffing their faces you know I simplify
I hosted too many shows that comedy
clubs when no one's paying attention to
you because you know that placing their
orders at the Times I just didn't want
to have that anymore so okay so in
thinking about something like a Highland
in ballroom compared to like a bar or a
restaurant this is a private venue that
does private events how do you approach
them in terms of you know the pay pretty
much you know like how do you say okay
let me do this event but I also want you
to pay me and just trust that I'll
deliver right well these days I try to
find you know it was it's a mix of
trying to find venue like I think I feel
like you have a better experience if
you're doing like bars and restaurants
those the ones are gonna be more likely
to give you like pie a small guarantee
mmm but with a venue like this so other
venues these days I try to find venues
that will just basically do a door deal
with me let me keep most if not all the
door you guys keep the you know liquor
sales and all that kind of stuff I'm
gonna kind of work out way like that you
know sometimes it's like a rental fee or
people a lot of venues wanted like a
50/50 split but my experience is I feel
like I can profit more by doing a door
deal you know it's nice to get a couple
hundred bucks as a guarantee but if
you're doing if you're selling tickets a
door and you could sell out you're gonna
make a lot more money and what is when
you say most of the money are we saying
like seventy five percent is a good
bargaining chip or something like that
like I said guys Tuesday I still do some
venues not so much and see well I do
like a 50/50 deal okay I check but these
days if I can't I get 100 percent of the
door yeah and I think yet they're kind
of earned that we have to kind of prove
yourself first and hurt it and then show
that they're gonna make money in other
aspects that's what I was gonna say
you've been doing Sweetwater for eight
years
yeah was it kind of like as you build
rapport and a reputation with them it's
like okay the door deal may have been
this but then we can we can start to
open that up more yeah okay and it
changed there because like when the beer
sales
laws changed here in Georgia so for the
first I know what six or seven years we
did that show Sweetwater they weren't
technically allowed to sell beer so it
was like samples now they're allowed to
beer so when that changed they want they
came at us about approaching it totally
differently because now they're trying
to you know sell doesn't make as much
money selling beers as they can so oh
look I helped us but her it hurts and
help us in hers in the same way so so
yeah that's why I noticed yeah the last
time I was at that show I think it
people were paying for the beer instead
of yeah tickets now I yeah now you pay
admission you should get like two beers
but then you have the option of buying
more beers afterwards which was never an
option beforehand okay so when it also
when we're thinking about making money
you know cuz this is something I
produced Java monkey for like seven
years and I was never really able to
retention was a struggle and I like how
you said here at virgin the Highland in
that you built a relationship with the
venue and it's grown together so maybe
talk about building a relationship with
the venue but then also your audience to
get them to come back yeah well I think
the both are very important both are
very important both are more important
than any of the aspect of the comi show
mmm I think I think of I think about the
people at the venue first and then I
think about the audience before I ever
think about who am i booking for this
show because then when I know those
elements it's gonna give me an idea of
who would be good to booked for the show
gotcha for me the relationship with the
with the venue and the people who work
there is the most important a guy like
you know that the this every show I'm
here I have the same two guys working
downstairs you know and as the
bartender's and not like that my friends
and I we text each other regularly we
stay we stay up and play video games
afterwards and for me that's always been
important cuz I've had you know some
experiences where I do a show sit like a
bar stuff and every time I show up it's
a different bartender or different
servers in half the time they might not
even know there's a comedy show
happening so having that kind of
relationship you know to the point now
here
well I literally have a key to the place
they date trust me enough to give me a
key to the venue so I can come and go as
I please Wow
so stuff like that like that that trust
level I think is important and then with
the audience it's I think that's equally
as important is figuring out who you're
like regulars and stuff like that are
and figure out who your core audience is
and then you know treating them almost
like friends you know like I feel like
I've been doing long enough where I
suppose I have fans
I don't think of them as like fans I
think I bother miss friends you know so
I think that's it that's another key
aspect to think of how do you develop a
relationship with your how do you make
your your what I recall them audience
members your friends how do you do that
ah just kind of like acknowledge them I
think is a little bit simplest at you
know a little simple thing like if I see
someone who's regularly coming to shows
out say hi to them or you know to shake
the hand think up for coming out stuff
like that actually I learned that I
think I learned that from Jerry far
above all people I'd ever been on here
yeah I did a run with Jerry where we did
some commies zones across like the
southeast and uh before the show he
would walk up to every single audience
member and shake their hands and thanked
them for being there and I thought that
was like kind when I got next to go that
approach by thought that was kind of
cool the video the perks of being a
one-man band
yeah you want to make it alright so do
you also greet the the guests as they
come in do you do anything like that to
Knicks Dan likes like I you know out
sometimes I set the door I'm just kind
of like hey how's it going I think I do
it more like the end of the show like
I'll make a point to try it like I'll
stand out in the lobby waiting people to
pass by but someone makes eye contact
with me out like a knot you know like I
tried like you know I think if you get
like I don't know that cuz activist
Angela it's like probably got 10% 20%
people who are like hardcore fans and
those are the people who you noticed I
want to acknowledge and for Malaysia it
just kind of thing it just happens
naturally like and those people are the
best people because those are the ones
we're gonna keep bringing they're gonna
bring their friends I can tell everyone
the people who truly are invested into
the show those are the ones that you
know I do like a strategic thing it just
kind of happens because you mentioned a
second ago to find your core audience
how did you find your core audience well
first off I think this kind of found me
like you tell cuz they'll like you'll
see someone to show through times then
they send you like a friend request on
facebook or something well they start
talking to you after show stuff like
that you know you see interactions
online and stuff like that there's a guy
actually comes to all the shows almost
all the shows here and then I was in
Nashville recently and he
at the show there turns out he's a huge
fan of dusty slaves I thought this guy
came all the way from Elena to see me no
turns out he was just like you know I
just happen to also be there
bass is someone that wants the examples
of someone's it's a really like a real
big fan of comedy mm-hmm those people I
think like I think we own a boom right
now Mikami is really popular because of
people like that
people like I think there's also
probably more good comedy now than it
ever has been before so it's kind of
like a perfect mix of things yeah that's
why I wanted to do this episode at this
time because comedy is booming and I
would like to empower comedians to you
know take advantage of this boom and
build an audience because not only are
you building your business but you're
actually able to build an audience and a
following and people who will that you
can then be like hey I have merger hey
I've got this going on but I'll engage
with you right now I think that was an
important aspect is when I did one comi
I focused I started focusing more on the
brand that I did on myself which I think
in some ways has hey hey who has that
has had positive impacts on my career
boss negative positive the fact that I
have these successful shows but I'm not
necessarily as successful as a comedy is
I may be imagined myself to as I would
be 10 years in you know but I think I
found success in other avenues like you
know but like I feel like I'm a I feel
like I'm a pretty good comic but I feel
like I'm a really good show producer
mm-hm
and embracing that aspect you know and
seeing like this is when I'm really good
at let's focus on this and focus on
building this brain and stuff like that
so it's funny you're like I'm 10 you I'm
10 years in and we all go through that
mindset we were like but yeah when you
start comedy you're like oh but I want
to be on Comedy Central but now it's
like you could take a step back and be
like oh well I have a podcast I am
consistently working I'm getting to do
comedy full-time exactly yeah great
you have your own production company
you're doing comedy full-time so I think
it's it's good especially now with
comedy booming and everyone wanting to
try comedy having that perspective of
not looking at the 1% of comedy and
being like no that's comedy it's like
what we're doing is comedy yeah
there's different paths for everyone yes
yeah exactly and now the idea is that
yeah I think you know I first I imagined
myself be on Comedy Central now I
imagine myself producing a show for
Comedy Central I think I'd rather do
that you know like for me putting
together the overall picture and seeing
the ecstasy is you know more rich thing
than a good set can be you know seen the
overall show succeed like I see you know
everyone on the show do good like that
for me is amazing yeah you have big
vision in terms of your looking you
don't do something like the Fox Theater
like yeah yeah yeah I've never been I've
been actually never actually been to the
Fox the exact boys boy you should say I
was waiting to I perform there but now
I'm gonna die like to produce the show
there yeah give a timeline on that when
you're trying now what is whenever okay
before I'm dead I guess you know I
didn't know how structured your business
was cuz you're doing multiple shows a
week and you seems like you do have some
infrastructure behind this hey dude yeah
actual structure behind it a little bit
I try to like live in the moment as much
as possible but now so many things are
being thrown at me like now if the last
few you know fuse I've really succeed on
just producing showcases but now other
comics are hitting me up like hey we'd
love to come do and come through and do
a headliner [ __ ] stuff like that like I
just booked a guy who's like a viral
sensation from Scotland who I I had
never heard of but they reached out to
me as okay let's put together and he's
selling fast his tickets are selling
faster than anyone else I've ever dealt
with so to seeing so kind of like it's
like a learning process the whole time
like figure out how okay I've had
success at this and this is how I've
thought this is how to do it now I'm
thinking is other different avenues to
it for success as well and booking shows
out hit used to be you know the idea of
booking myself a show four or five or
six months will now seem kind of far and
now I'm booking other comics that far
out Wow is there a specific thing in
terms of the actual show set up like
because I've heard we briefly touched on
this in the previous interview but it is
like the environment of the show itself
you mentioned kind of touched on like
the chairs and lighting and things like
that but maybe for a comedian also
looking at a venue or now they're at the
venue they're like okay how can I set
this up for success what are some tools
or tips or strategies you've learned
that really set up a show to be a
success I think where you have a room
where the focus of everyone in that room
is gonna be the whatever the weather cuz
where does a stage not should be on the
performer mm-hmm so every chair should
be aimed at the performer every light
should be aimed at the performer that
you try to avoid as many distracts thats
why i like food at food because also if
your food it tends to be tables i hate
having tables at common shows because
tables encourage discussion like we are
right now like when you're the table
you're used to talking other people from
so from my experience if you have a
table those crowd members are far more
likely to talk to each other
i want every single chair facing the
face in the stage where that's all they
see that it's it's gonna be much harder
that kind of look over to talk to their
friend and i feel like that kind of a it
makes it less likely it's gonna happen
so yes I think the SEPA room it whatever
room you're in
everything should be focused on the
performance aspect mm-hmm so you know no
obviously no TVs on stuff like that you
know have all the like if there's
lighting in the room it should all be in
the comic like my biggest gripe is me
show up to a venue in the hall
they say like a bar and the bars lit up
but then when we're performing is like
dark that drives me crazy so stuff like
that just kind of focus on you know
haven't everyone's attention I'm what's
going on in that moment even the comics
what I what I respect about your shows
is a lot of the show's comics will just
be in the back just kind of dilly-dally
and but like if we're talking you're
like gosh yeah I mean I'm not actually
so simple here I have specific seating
areas for the comics if you if you wanna
be in the show room you have to be in
one of those areas you don't have to be
in the show but you can't be standing in
the back that again it takes away from
the show but yeah you know I said well
like 9% running a show was just telling
other comics to shut up and I'm guilty
of it myself you know if I could other
shows and I'm not focused on the
production accident I can get caught up
in that moment too but yeah I think
she's like a respect thing like a beaut
if you're an eye sight of the performer
they you know you should be focus on
them or not be in the room mm-hmm
because it drives me crazy when I'm on
stage I can see comics in the back top I
get I especially on my own shows like I
just I just Sweetwater recently and this
last mundane the whole time
I was on stage I saw two comics at the
bar talking and I couldn't I was out of
the moment because that's all I could
think about was wine I walk up to him
and say hey guys just quit talking you
know and I almost it was it was it took
everything in me not to say that while
was on stage because I didn't want to
take away from the I am I draw attention
to what's happening so stuff like that
yeah and like controlling the room
controlling the comic is drawing
audience because for me you know people
complain about like bachelorette parties
or drunk people shows they're easy to
handle it's the comics were a lot her
take comics also have egos yeah
sometimes you have to be some people are
pretty fragile if you go up and ask em
to quit you know to quit talking that
you know sometimes you get some some
gruff from them you know so yeah I think
it's control basically you want a room
where you can control every aspect of
that room and that's why I love doing
shows here at the High Line in because
not only do I really have a key to the
place but you know I'm able to control
the soundboard I'm able to control this
light for a lot of places you go to and
they have their own person who does that
which is fine but just one more element
that I don't have control over oh you
know even like sweet white we bring in
our own lighting we bring our own sound
we're bringing our own share it's just
so we can have complete control of
everything that's happening there
control yeah control yeah because
something we don't have control over
life and you don't really have control I
think in many ways over your career but
if you can control the aspects of the
show that kind that's something you
can't have control over what are some
other mistakes comics make when it comes
to even getting booked or yeah how they
I guess we kind of touched on them at
the show itself but even comics I know
from booking a show for like seven years
how annoying comedians are and you're I
booked one show yeah a week you're
booking several what are some tips you
have for comics on hey these are these
are a few things to help you get booked
tomorrow right I am very nautical that
were calcaneal got interviewed and he
talked about how before he blew up he
was like 10 11 years in and he would
never ask for spots and his mindset he
just wanted to be Tryg as fine as he
could so the other people would ask him
the do shows so I think that's important
is kind of waiting your time and I was
going bad about that when I started off
early
message every Booker in the world trying
to get like yeah I think it's like when
the two weeks is doing comedy I was like
messaging comedy clubs and like you know
classic ranching said hey I saw a CG
update would tell us we can I would love
to oh you know like just so I think it's
kind of this would be patient like this
it's it's from you know some people have
a fast track to success Akaya but most
people don't and I think you know you
have to kind be humble and just patient
and just wait for your moment I'm lucky
enough I think some a lot I think we
ever seen now if people kind of learn
quickly that the best way to get up is
just kind of be funny and wait mmm and
also think I have enough shows that get
people in pretty regularly but you
usually what happens like maybe Newark
Kasich hit me up and I kind of like you
know hey out I'll get to you when I get
to you you know and I'll say quite like
that I've seen that guy mean a book
every I approach every show differently
and I book almost like I have shows for
months out by a kind of approach okay
what's this week's show you know I know
I know but I tried to book out too far
and that's the second you know like an
out-of-town comic or someone visiting or
someone has like you know like I'm
helping Dedrick Flynn record his album
you know I guess so stuff like that
special moments or some of the hey I'm
filming this thing I love you know I'd
like to get some stage time so there are
some exceptions but for the most part I
tell people like I'll get you know kind
of get to you you know and you know if I
if I booked you for this show Spa give
me a while before I booked you for
another show and I'm like but you know I
if you if you're funny out any on your
you know respectful of the craft I will
eventually book you on one of my shows
is hanging out important and like
showing up to your shows even if you're
not on I think definitely helps is logic
being you know respectful of the show
it's funny because I think a lot of
comics didn't like I knew I know that I
know that I definitely how it got booked
for shows so especially like clubs just
by being there and you know I won't say
club specifically but as a local club
where I knew if I showed up on Tuesday
or Wednesday to check it out chances are
the Booker was gonna hit me up that
Thursday about doing weekend shows first
is if I reached out to them I might not
have got as much response I think that
does help I get this especially my shows
Casino I sometimes suppose it show up so
if someone's day I you know you might
photo get up just by being there I
probably have put Greg Barron's on more
shows just by being and I had
book timbi's yes he's he's hangs out
he's respectful if I need someone I know
he's gonna succeed I think sometimes it
hurts connaissez they'll come and they
they're more social and then my my I
just don't wanna book them they're like
there are a handful of comics who come
to a lot of shows and every time I have
to come ask him not to talk during my
show and being a so then there they go
they move to that they they do I won't
say but they move to end up my list they
just don't they just get erased from my
list of people who I eventually want a
book you know how do they reach out in
terms of like an email well you have a
form on your website now yes when people
reach out to me now I usually tell them
if it's someone I don't know
so I usually say hey here's a submission
and I'd say 99% don't even go through
with it yes that's a great filter yeah
do this one extra step to get to this
and literally like 90 percent of people
are like exactly yeah you're like oh
they weren't really caring anyway yeah
I'm the same way like you know I think
if you want to like you know feature or
headline clubs allow them you have to
send your avails all the stuff and I
haven't lease exceeded that because
that's something I just don't my mind so
I just don't it's something I do
mmm-hmm I'm lucky enough that I have a
lot of my own shows I don't necessarily
have to go try to get booked for other
things and is there a way to phrase when
they are reaching out is there because
I've had some people be like yo let me
get a spot or I'm in town let's do this
like they want you they don't even
there's no professionalism behind do you
do you pay attention to how they contact
you definitely a little bit of that like
you can like for me yeah you could tell
who's good at because that will there's
the professional is I said a lot of
times like I can usually tell a lot of
times if they want to get booked out
usually people who drop a references and
it's usually good references mmm like so
one sells like I in sometimes it's bad
references I know like okay just stay
away but locally a lot of times like
you've new Cosima quite tom is I just is
it's true I do a lot of my booking in
person whether ID whether I see you at a
show and I say hey come to my show or I
message you afterwards
I don't book anyone local who I've never
seen performed before so you know and I
mean I would say I'm kind of bad about
going on to other shows now but there's
even necessary to be someone I see
perform if I see like you know if I see
like the Laughing skulls book in you or
a neighbor's book in you then I know
this person's good and I think it goes
the other way it goes the other way
around if they see I'm booking someone
who they've never heard of or never seen
then they know it that they're good a
book mm-hmm so I think it's just you
know proving yourself there's a lot of
ways to prove yourself and I think you
have to go through that process I think
a lot people like trying fast rocket you
know where's like I know where like 10
years in I think people realize that
sometimes it takes that long to get any
kind of success you know it's not you
know and I think what happens is a lot
people start off and they wanna just
jump right into and I was that way too
and I think when I did it it was quite a
lot easy because it was a lot less
comics you know right well I did it I
started a star bar when there was maybe
10 15 comics in general trying to get up
okay you hit Rodney up on MySpace yeah
yeah yeah the first change basically had
to tell Rodney you were coming and now
there's hundreds of comics trying to buy
for that spot so it's it seems like
every year if you start off as a new
comic it's gonna get tougher and tougher
and tougher unless you're just really
really good mm-hm and 1% of comics are
probably really really good and then one
percenter them up I can't go on to
actually succeed so but it also depends
on what your definition of success I
know plenty of comics you know Landon
who are just happy to perform like they
you know they have their they do
whatever else they're doing they don't
have dreams of movement off to new york
at la they're just happy to be involved
with the scene and be involved with a
group and get up and perform and I you
know and I'm happy to have those people
I think I think it's different levels
you have a little bit of everyone yeah
it's important to be selective in your
show to when we're talking about
retention and getting people to come
back if you sell out a venue but then
the comics on there aren't great
yeah well aren't going to come back yeah
if it's the same that's nothing is
variety and I think we're lucky enough
here only I we have lots of cons but you
also have a lot of comics coming through
mm-hmm so for example this weekend I
have three shows here at Highland every
show has a different lineup you know and
not necessarily people can come to every
single show but I want you to know if
you'd come to one of these shows you can
have a different experience every single
time so I think that's important you
know and that takes a little bit of work
you know figure out who you booked and
who you like and also variety in the
sense that you don't book the same
people over again but for I in a sense
to everyone the shows
a little different ah yes you know you
know does it doesn't mean just come down
to like Saks and race just style all
that stuff like make sure if I book ten
comics I want ten different perspectives
on life and that's why I think you know
cuz you might not you might like one you
might not like the other but you can get
a variety gonna get a live different you
know takes on comedy and this show we're
talking about started out as a Friday
show and it has since grown into a
Thursday and Saturday show yeah well we
just did the first second ever Thursday
show last night and that was actually
Monday or like Sunday I was here Sunday
and we realized there was nothing else
going on until my shows fry and salia so
we were like so I'm Monday we decided
hey why not do a Thursday show and we
had like 40 people come out last night
which isn't a big crowd but the fact
that we just saw I put it online Monday
and then we had 40 people come out last
night which is kind of cool that last
minute yeah yeah where's five our
biggest day is Friday because people
know that Friday is like what happens
sometimes we're not here and then
there's other events here and people
show up thinking it's ten buck and oh I
see they make they might come to show
that oh it might be a wedding and like
okay wait a minute this is not happening
so I've tried to find out different ways
to you know stay in constant contact
with our regulars and ah yes like that
are you collecting emails what's your
what's your section I am so I use fresh
tickets follow my online sales and they
maintain an email database so it's
really easy for me what I do is let's go
through and I click one little button
and it sends out an email to everyone
who's ever bought a ticket from me so I
just I just did earlier this week whoa
to promote the show last night and we
have like you know some like to 3,000
people because of that so and then fresh
tickets it's in a local company to who
I've worked really close with so finding
different elements like that like
finding other people you know not
necessary the venue but the people you
work in ticketing like like I think I'm
lucky to be in LA we have you know
multiple people doing multiple things we
can all kind of work together yeah cuz
you've always been on the branding piece
as well you've always had posters and
you're you're always you always look at
it from every angle that polish yeah
exactly yeah which is local artists you
have involved in that as well yeah yeah
usually if I have a post design
something it's almost always a local
comic to some
involved in the comi scene so I and then
you know I have I have you know people
the people work my door at comics that
people who do my sound a comic so that
was another thing is I learned that I
could find if I succeed at producing a
production company I can then employ
comics to do stuff about because that's
the thing is there's not really much
money in the performance aspect you know
even people who succeed who you know you
seen doing like calm Central specials up
like that they usually making money
doing other things with his writing or
whatever else is very realistic there's
very little money in the actual
performance aspect yes you have to find
those other niches to get paid and do
stuff like that so it's funny sometimes
you know I mean these days I'm able to
book you know pretty much pay every
comic of my show might not be much but
if you work in the door you can get much
more money you know so I like the idea
of been a employee comics and stuff like
that
even my even might get posters printed I
use a comic who lives out of state but
he's a comic who works on who works it
for a printing company so all the money
I'm putting out there's going towards
other comics this guy yeah yeah he's
come I see at the mayoral and cop I
think I need to move on so now I live in
Mill insects yeah yeah but the may have
comedy I guess works yeah I love ya I
love your aspect too reinvesting into
comedy as well and that's why I mean
that's why I do this podcast as well is
giving comics like all this insight that
I get asked about shows I got asked
yesterday about like how do I approach a
venue or things like that and I was like
well I know the expert yeah like I've
done some shows but this guy it's his
like job right to do this yeah it's my
passion to like you know here here we
are in a county podcast and I feel like
like my tour my girlfriend's doing it
she's like what are you gonna be doing
outside so it's got to be funny I was
like no it's like copy late but that guy
but this is like I'm not the person who
likes to sit after a show and like riff
and stuff I write yeah I mean I don't
like but I will sit down and talk about
I'll talk about all the other aspects of
comedy you know like the production
aspect of the booking product that's
what I find that's what I'm passionate
about you know yes because even my own
stand-up I don't like I don't write I
don't I don't sit down to write I don't
know I'm real bad about that
I don't think about what I'm gonna go
because I
usually I say nights and the shows I do
on my own so I'm usually focused on
every other aspect and then it comes
down to Showtime and I have one minute
to go oh I'm about to go on stage so I
live just going on stage and then kind
of figure it out from there so yeah I
think I my passion is to figure out all
the other aspects I figured out what
makes a perfect show mm-hmm because when
you perform on the show you're just one
tiny part of it but if you're the
producer of the show you get to like I
said have control over the whole aspect
but now it's into me and I go to other
people shows now I'm like I want to dim
the lights or like do different things I
like tweak things you know
I'll give like sometimes I have come off
a little strong hey maybe should do this
you know but I'm trying to help you so I
think and that that's why I want to
empower comics to at least try your own
show so you have a whole new respect for
when you're at other comedy shows that
are run well just all the work that goes
in to a well-run show yeah like he I get
you know I got here but before this I
was setting up chairs and stuff like I
get I get to it like it's really I'm
producing a show like I usually show up
to the venue no no less than like two
hours in advance whereas if I'm
performing on the show I'm usually there
two minutes before the show starts right
right because I know how shows work like
I think thankfully here Leah a lot
people who I succeeded shows have
learned like you know there's all the
different elements of success for a
comedy show but the pilot most important
is starting on time boom it was close to
on time as possible that was the thing I
failed it a lot early I as I would hold
off sometimes 30 minutes 45 an hour to
start the show hoping that more people
show up and you end up just upsetting
the people who did show up on time so
now Greg Baron says the best reasons
like you know we award the people show
up on time you know because I think ah
so if you do even if you do start a show
on time and people do show up late I
think they're more inclined to be like
oh I should get here earlier next time
what stuff like that what about the
duration of the show what the link
exchange is like something like even the
show I do Highland sometimes a mate
sometimes it's two hours you know just
it just depends on who's around who's at
AB I think if it's good enough it can do
well like I had a you know show recently
where Dave way and
sheamus were in town so I've gave him
both like 20 minutes each on top of
where we were already 80 minutes and it
was a long show but they were that level
where they could pull it off and they
still pulled the crowd and stuff like
that but my ideal show is like 75
minutes like 90 minutes topic if I could
do like like ride do these other small
like smaller satellite shows I may only
have two or three other comments to try
keep like 75 minutes to 80 minutes okay
like that's what we do is sweet why're
we hit about 80 minutes for now but we
also open up in our head time so people
can come drink ahead you know drink
hangout and then we try to get be done
so they have like an animator next 30
minutes to sort of hang out afterwards
as well by thinking oh like 90 minutes I
think is ideal it should be like your
peak if you can unless it's just a
really really good you like star bar for
example it's like a three hour show
think you know the crowd kind of comes
and goes but it's always a crowd but
always weather you know necessary the
comics aren't always the best on the
show because the brownie will give other
people chances it's a show that you know
is gonna be good for the most but you
don't know you never know who's gonna
show up so it keeps you in thrall
advisor
star bar is an example of a show that's
built the trust with the audience
exactly yeah so they've built the trust
to go three hours and maybe have some
hit or misses but overall it's gonna be
a good experience
exactly experience yeah yeah good
experience I think that every show
should be an experience mm-hmm you know
you want them stepping away thinking
they you know they just experience
something you know yeah what's and
that's you know ideally a memorable one
ideally a good memorable one D but even
if it's a bad memorable one still an
experience you know something's gonna
stick with them yeah cuz you'll do the
theme shows as well and under our show
and the roasts and things like that but
actually you mentioned comic do you care
just real quick what time comics get
there is that something comics a mindful
of not really designs for the most part
of designs they show up on time or if
they don't they're okay if I'm gonna put
them wherever I put them I think most
comics are cool about that but it's fine
right new accounts of new people are
booked it's a yes it's my own great by
the shape you know because it's what
they should be doing but it's funny what
concept sometimes reach out to me go
what's the call time and I just say try
get that before the show starts you know
like okay cuz if they they get the two
relates is more stuff I have to deal
with them like cuz I I'm not because I
I don't think about the lineup in
advance I usually do the lineup as
people are showing up or sometimes five
minutes before we start and though the
people who can tell I'm more
professional I'm more into it than other
types throughout like you don't ask when
they're going up there like they wait
til you tell them you go you can be the
third comic in and go oh yeah I have you
go in seventh and like okay cool like
they did prepare to go up whenever they
have to go up whereas you can kind of
tell like you know that make the new
acaso show up let's do you have a lineup
what am I going up you know which is
fine and then they ask you again yeah
yeah the skew repeated times yeah what
am I going up am i next
how many more yes yes as long as you
show up and if you don't show up there's
people something I'm not the person who
get up sex I know things happen maybe
you ought to tell me and I'm gonna
forget about anyway but as long as you
show up for the most part I'm okay
but again be cool if we're I'm gonna put
you up okay my biggest gripe is when
comics show up five minutes after the
show I joined they're not they weren't
there when I started the show so I don't
have it on the line and they show up
call non-aligned go get what your number
seven and they're like oh okay go up
earlier like what you weren't here yeah
so like that's look like those are the
types like that kind like for me that's
the kind of stuff that is most likely
gonna prevent me from wanna put you back
up you know boom that's exactly what I
was just thinking you do not forget I'm
telling you there were comics on my show
that ran the light belligerently
oh yeah and they were never back exactly
you never forgot yeah yeah things like
that I feel like belligerent these fun
like a Manitou over of course oh yeah
I'll pipe I'll forget by the next comic
and it'll come up ah just but if you
belligerent about it literally I will
never book ever again that's the one
thing I'll think about stuff like that
that and like costly if I have to tell
you one two times and not talk during
the show I'm fine I can I have a book
you the mayor yeah these days I just
tell people like hey if I knew who had
stalkers I just you say hey I want you
to step outside you know I'll go back
there go somewhere else alright so here
we go Joe we've talked about the venue's
we've talked about oh the comics and
tips and how to build your audience or
engage with them at the show marketing
let's let's let's go headfirst into
marketing because this is the bridge
between us to show a show like
or a show just like sustaining or
failing is that marketing piece and
there's so many different theories about
what works and what doesn't but you
announce a show on a Monday and then
Thursday you can get 40 people out there
what is your approach to marketing uh
engagement the guys to do posters and
ads and stuff a guy knows all work but
for me engagements what's most important
also providing all the information like
I for me
say like a good Facebook event page is
something that has every all the
information possibly like where's where
is it what's the address what's the
parking situation what's the age limit
what time outdoor is what time does the
show start stuff like that how much does
it cost of like that and then constant
engagement what do you mean by
engagement like for example well I think
a lot of people especially on Facebook
don't take advantage of is there's a
place on invents to post stuff so
leading up the show like for example
when we do the roasts up maybe the week
singer once a week up post like hey
here's a silly meme about what we're
doing here's the ticket link and then
leading up to it here tonight's show we
have tonight's show here you go constant
engagement like that where as I see the
fan pages or whether you know you have
the whole discussion aspect answer is
completely empty because every time you
post us up like that or engage something
they can be notified whether they
looking at or not it's constantly
reminding them about this thing so I
think engagement not just on you know on
social media but other aspects website
stuff like that kind of doing the emails
with that but engage in your audience
constantly remind them that you exist
mmm
where is I think that's more important
than China folk then trying to
accumulate new audience members trying
to keep the ones you already have
because again I think word-of-mouth is
does I think the most successful
marketing if you have someone who's
interesting what you do they will tell
other people about it and that to me is
more valuable than any like Facebook ad
or Instagram or anything like that so
yeah constantly engaging in an
appreciation showing people like I you
know when I do sell these emails off
like you know off like half off coupons
or something like that promo codes like
teeth and different different avenues I
offer different things just shy engage
people and show them like hey I
appreciate you here's something she
knows it so for example last night
the for people who are they also here
here's a promo code to get a free show
next time you want to come stuff like
that just okay we appreciate you coming
out last minute here's a reward for
coming out you know here's some other
stuff you know so constantly engaging
and rewarding your audience members I
think is more important than anything
you could do advertising wise the guy
died I don't I don't spend any money on
advertising anymore I actually do like
Facebook ads even posters I hardly ever
get posters made up because from my
experience word-of-mouth engagement is
what has the most successful he doing a
show here helps because of how much
growth has happened I think we got a lot
of people from the neighborhood I would
say yesterday making the sign and two
different people approached me who I
never I don't recognize but their tutor
people approached me who come to the
shows
hi well I wrote Thursday Friday and
we'll my gun guys yeah cuz it me go it
was George's day Rex I have a whole bit
about going George date oh because hey
he goes I was from Auburn where I come
from we put the D and Thursday he points
out I'd misspelled Thursday but it's a
guy I'd am recognized by music yeah I
mean my wife we love your shows we might
come out to nicest stuff like that it's
kind of cool yeah yeah and yeah it's
important you have a sign out front
you're like a one of sandwich board
signs out front of the vineya and they
provide the venue provide that spicy
deca duty poses a lot of stuff and now
like they have it you know the signs up
warehouse one upcoming our website they
you know they did that for me like I'd
even ask I showed up one day and that
was just there it's nothing I talked
about and it just kind of happened so
again having a venue that's 100% behind
you why don't emphasize behind you that
they will go out of their way to do
stuff like that and promote the shows
and whatnot but yeah I think yeah but
maintain eyes and engagements like the
most important thing and you turn out
the area around here booming do you hang
up posters or any do you do any other
advertising at the other local
businesses or apartment complexes or
anything
I used to began not I haven't done in a
while out the guy I don't think I've put
up a single poster flyer this year I
used to like Forks it with the underwear
show I used to fly the heck out of
george's day and I haven't done that in
the numbers have actually gone down so I
think that was one show okay the
definitely benefit because Georgia is
right next to Village deer so can I help
and it would pull in a college class I
like that
so something I need I need to be better
about
she for like more like one-off shows I
think that helps to advertise but I
think if you build a good like you know
sweet not to be water but star bars in
that example of that they don't have
appetite because people just know about
it or even sweet water we do we don't
really market that that much because
people just are just aware of it you
know and hopefully I hopefully they're
aware of it and then it's funny people
show up ago I never heard this and we
didn't use it's like I never heard the
show that's even back and now they're
engaged by it like I've never heard I
can't believe I've been missing out in
this I want to come all the time now so
yeah I think it's a mix I think you know
if you're starting off a show it helps
to have posters especially in the venue
you're performing it and you know I
think cuz that's you know if you if
you're starting up any a new shown a new
venue your core audience is gonna be
people who already you know support that
venue and boom so if they go to the
bathroom and see a post you know if
they're there every night and they see a
poster for your show every night it's
gonna be oh that's cool might want to
check that out you know or if it's the
first time there they make a hole I
might come back for this so here like
you know like again we have the science
out front so everyone who's walking by
everyone who sees the venue you know
laughs this goes a great example if you
drive down Peachtree Street you can't
help but notice Laughing Skull you know
so you know it's the whether you've been
there not you know it's there and so if
you think calm you might think oh I'm
gonna go check out this place and you
mentioned you used to do Facebook ads
which sounds like it could be a good way
to build your audience well what's your
strategy with Facebook Ads it was a mix
like for a lot of times out focus like
it feels like say like the 10 bucks show
I'd focus on advertising to my already
built-in audience when we do the
character roast sometimes I still do
them for those and I market them towards
fans of whatever I'm doing because you
can pick like when you do like a
Facebook ad you can pick like who do you
want who do you want to see this so if
we're doing like say you know roast look
we're doing the roaster game of thrones
coming up I would do fans of Game of
Thrones I would do fans of Johnson I
would like to pick every specific
character and have different elements
that and then you know you can choose
your your age you know geographically
you can choose which is fine because
I'll see ads he's on Facebook or
Instagram for shows like in Los Angeles
assume that yeah I'm like are you guys
not paying attention to your marketing
I think a lot of times people just go oh
push that - commie fans which could be a
lot what you end up just gonna be
promoting two comics you know so I think
it's if you are going to spend money
advertise and you want to be real
strategic about who you like marketing
to the right people
mm-hmm you know niche audiences stuff
like that what about the wording of your
ads um I change - I try again be
engaging like make it sound
conversational guys I see so many words
just like Thursday something this you
know it's just it's the basic core info
I tried like hey you know like Oh like
make a little funny joke or something I
kind of stole the I what you know a lot
of corporations are doing our you just
kind of you just use memes cuz I think
that's a huge right now that engages
people and gets people's attention hmm
but yeah just for stuff like that you
know and then you know finding out like
what works and what doesn't work like
for example on Facebook for everything
the helga rhythm hates words on images
so for me like what I try to use that
like I just try using like a real simple
image like if you look at the beer and
comedy event it's just a photo of me and
jamming on stage before audience looks
like they having a good time and I think
that's more engaging than you know of
image with all like I think you know put
it put the info somewhere else but
doesn't have an S it be what they the
aim on the image
I guess you see - I see too many where
I'll have the name of the show the time
the price it's like way too much
information on image for it to get out
there hello knocking maybe is the door
locked I don't know yeah someone's
trying to come and get coffee or
something yeah come on in you come you
come on in there yeah okay cool thank
you
they were coming here when I was setting
up oh sorry I just want some water I was
like you can't drink water yeah yeah
come on this isn't Flint you're saying
about my take some of your water
take it away man maybe we both should
yeah you have a little fountas break
here cheers to you sir
yeah stay hydrated mmm I'm bad
hmm but you know speaking of drink I
would say my the biggest aspect of my
success was quitting booze I was just
asking yeah it's over yeah yeah I uh I'm
not I like cuz I'm sorry I guess hit
four years in February Congrats in that
time period I've had maybe 10 beers
throughout those for you I'll still like
it sweet while if they have a new beer
I'll stand point every single time and
I'll get I'll drink like one sip and get
that five minute buzz no even that five
minute like exactly don't do it but then
you know in many ways has helped you
know has helped me in so many ways and
I'll just I just have more time and more
money to focus on all the other aspects
mm-hmm
so I think you know stepping away from
the party aspect of it and focusing more
on the professional aspect of it has
helped me in so many ways I agree I
think I'm more likable I'm more fun to
be around now people want to be around
me mm people like you know he's trouble
so I don't want to be around you yeah I
remember the yeah I remember the Jesus
Joe yeah yeah I used that long hair a
beard we were we did spuds yeah it was a
strip mall restaurant known for potatoes
yeah I wonder why it fails yeah but that
was like the first place I think we ever
met and yeah I was like who is this guy
like I have a show to Moose Lodge I go
to a Moose Lodge we're getting heckled
by an old guy drunk with an oxygen tank
yeah Kermit we're like what is happening
yeah yeah now I you know I want the hunt
I want the performance to be the
experience not everything else seen but
you had to fail to learn exactly you
know all those failures are lessons
right and you probably had more shows
failed and succeed when you think of the
average just like your no absolutely and
way more jokes failed and succeed yeah
same thing with a show I think about
even doubt now but you know up until
really the last four or five years you
know most of us even the last couple
years I've done shows at venues did it
ma'am only works like two or three
months and then it kinda
doesn't pan out you know and I think
every single time we both parties would
just not want to percent into it it's
what happened so that seems to be is
that the biggest reason you think shows
fail is that either the venue's not
whoever's behind it or the performers
aren't or the producer isn't everyone's
got to be Bob I think so yeah yeah
because I you know in here you know this
is what I've had the most success I
think it was Highland is because they
wanted to set behind me and I love being
here like I said that's why I show up I
guess I showed to most shows two hours I
show up here high five six hours early
mostly because I'm trying to forward
traffic boss wide to get everything set
up and that can be comfortable and I
kind of hang out it's a great
neighborhood I can go walk and get like
flu or something like that mm-hmm
so just you know being involved and
being around stuff like that or as I
think a lot of people you see field
shows it's because the content that host
is showing up like you know 15 minutes
before the show is going through the
motions and stuff like that especially
open mics and stuff like that yeah we
just started to an open mic here where I
have Rachel Epstein and Spencer Taylor
house and I picked them safely because
they they add like an interesting new
kind of element to it and they have fun
with it you know they make it so it's
not just you're an open mic it's fun for
the comics and week actually getting
highlights because it's fun for them as
well they're not just going through the
motions ago the screen on stage I'm
performing front of you know other
comics again it's like what what can we
do differently to make this more
engaging yeah and to to to hosts the
other no they switch the switch
okay but because then because it's both
of them they they come in with different
ideas stuff like that I think that's
what you see a lot of success nowadays
is shows where they have multiple
producers like even you know even like
yes even speed while you know Jeremy me
see
here's to get the credit that he
deserves cuz he's been by my side the
whole time and we're officially
co-hosted couple juices but I think a
lot of people put that on me but if it
wasn't for him that show would exist cuz
he was there guiding me along in my
troubled times and to this day
bailing you out yeah exactly bailing me
out of jail so I can make you know gave
me all the hospital so I can make it
stuff like that but you know we put
Mikey see things that I don't see and I
see things that he don't see so to have
that kind of just have different
perspectives on how things should go I
would agree from someone who produced a
show alone
yeah for seven years and seeing the
success I had overall with it
you know in terms of an audience being
built in things I would highly recommend
teaming up yeah I'm doing a show if you
want to succeed there are so many
different responsibilities that if you
put it all on your shoulders like yo
yeah it's something's gonna break and I
said you know here this shows that
highlight pretty much produced by myself
I have other people help I have other
people in other aspects you know like
when we do the roast and you know I put
up there like who I put out to the
Congress what should we do this time was
come up some suggestions what should we
do and then I you know said I have you
know comics working the door and comics
working Sal and stuff like that so I I'm
producing if I have other people helping
me of the other small element stuff like
that mm-hmm
thankfully the show itself is kind of
easy it's just a showcase where there's
you know there's a never-ending influx
of comics who are available to do it who
want to do it so that's the easy fine
Cox is kind of easy it's all the other
aspects you have to kind of you know
think about and whatnot would you
recommend a comic who's thinking about
starting a show would you recommend they
start an open mic or a book showcase
it's like what's the yeah what what's
the best route to kind of get your foot
in the door maybe yes
that's a weird one because you know it's
Harvey wants to sit showcases of how
miserable it is to run an open mic but
that might be the best way to kind of
figure out the kinks of stuff I could
figure out like what how things work and
how things don't work is if it's open
mic I think there's less pressure about
it being one two percent good right and
you can have probably a little bit more
success getting people out you know like
if you have a mic you know we also have
to focus I try and make it a group of
mic tickets if it's just another bad
open mic is just gonna die out yeah but
I think you know focus on that you can
also you know especially if you're newer
it's gonna help you learn the scene and
learn new comic stuff like that too
often I think people are early on well
myself and clearly we'll start doing
showcases and they just book the comics
they know over and over and over again
and so it that kind of takes away from
it so today I guess it depends on also
finding out what the venue wants these
days I sometimes I get venues and
sometimes sometimes you also have to
find what the venue must fossil fighting
for what you want times I put by
does anyone do an open mic now Mike I
don't want ya I had to tell Michael
keeping my few up Mike it's an open
forum you're gonna have anyone come in
and say whatever they want and so that
is like okay well it's maybe [ __ ]
something else yeah or it's game or you
are 45 minutes outside the city it's
gonna be hard to get comics every week
to show up to do an open mic but if you
have a book showcase and you have
incentives like pay of comp meals stuff
like that it's gonna get better comics
out you know so I think it just depends
on what you trying to get out of it
yourself so when you are talking to
these venues how do you talk about the
money specifically like howdy how do you
bring it up are you first like are you
interested in the show and then it's
like okay here's my idea for the payment
or how do you trade those waters yeah
I'm still bad about that a lot of times
I just kind of a lot of times if
especially the doing if they're doing
like say like a music nyehhhh okay I
kind of like what do you do for this
worry what are you paying these guys and
a lot of times they'll kind of be honest
with you sometimes they'll come straight
forward to you but hey what what do you
need and I think sometimes I understand
understood myself trap now I kind of
overshoot myself to see if they'll go
for it and also that what is it gonna
make it worthwhile for me you know it's
a good number for what you need I think
you know if you like it depends on the
show what you want produce but for me I
get it's gonna be hard private be
hard-pressed to do a show really
anything less than like 200 or 250
dollars okay cuz that's you know I'm I
because I want to build a book
headliners and comps you know people I
want to pay the comics a decent amount
will also make a little bit money myself
but the ideal show is like a thousand
dollars you know but yeah if I can get a
thousand dollars I can put on the best
show in the world this that's why I
doing more of a door deal because it's a
gamble you got to get people to show up
to make money but then you have more a
chance at making that like you probably
can't buy a bar square one to give you a
thousand bucks but you might find a bar
as willing to give you a hundred or two
hundred bucks you know and you can still
put on a good show for that whether
you're keeping all them on yourself or
paying out the comics or just using the
money for advertising I think you need
something to scent avise everyone you
know was I feel like if any it feels
like they're putting something forward
to but this Austin you know like I think
you know there's plenty of room for free
shows as well if you just trying to
build
you know you were poor like I did plenty
of shows for you know I did the show of
five to nine the open mic that still
exists I did I never made it a single
dime off that but was worth it to me to
build that rapport at the venue and
build the scene up well the same thing
when we do the open mic here there's no
money involved but we're building with
helping comics build themselves and
seeing new people and kinds of stuff
like that mm-hmm
so it's I think it's just it depends on
if again I think if you're if you're
doing comedy for money you're gonna if
you it's the wrong biz right yeah but if
you can find Vegas willing to give you
you know some kind of compensation that
definitely makes it worthwhile and I
think it's valuable just to be hosting a
show as well like it that I learned more
from hosting a show for seven years in
terms of being on stage that much and
interacting with an audience that much
I've learned more about how to do comedy
just from hosting a show yeah so even if
you're looking to just get more stage
time and host the show
I think producing your own show is a
great way to just get better at comedy
faster even if you're not getting paid
right yeah exactly
just for a reference you know Java
monkey full disclosure I would get
twenty five a show and then after like
four years I was like hey you know we've
been doing this a while how about 50
yeah okay she passed earlier so
literally for in the in the perspective
it's like Oh fifty dollars it's nothing
yeah literally nothing for the amount of
work that goes into a show and going
there every week so just perspective for
comics cuz they want to know numbers you
know it's like you said minimum 200 I
think that's a great starting point
don't undersell yourself but also have
perspective if you're two years in the
game and you're like I want to do my own
show well maybe maybe for free yeah yeah
but you're getting a lot of good hosting
experience that'll and also it's a great
way to build your audience and build
fans yeah and learn and figure it out
learn you learn you know yes yeah
are there any hosting tips you have for
them from your years of hosting ah yeah
to not put yourself over and that's
really hard as stand-up comics and
that's like a wrestling term but I think
you're so over yeah I think it's a host
you have to remember that you your main
role is to kind of keep the show all
together now is about you know
about my first I journey but I think a
lot of comics still do you know the kind
that the hosts who do bits in between
every comic and stuff like that focus
too much on themselves that takes away
from the show and it's and super obvious
to the audience and the comics it's
gonna know everyone so I think the key
for houses you know do your time upfront
it doesn't have to you know and that's
how you even have to do that well it's
all about just starting this show and
building up this is what we're doing
like I've done so many Road gigs like
these commies on one-nighters where they
have a house emcee Hulu just goes up it
goes hey guys thanks for coming out
here's here's some weird little thing
now here's your first comments like this
it's all about just we're here for
comedy now has two economy it definitely
helps you know if the host is really
funny and can engage the crowd like you
say I think I've grown more as a host
that's grown my comedy more than
anything you know because you have to
figure out wait how do I engage this
crowd immediately and how do I keep them
engaged to be ready for the next comic
it's not to say you can't you know do
stuff in between but I think it takes a
long time to get to that comfort level
you know but yeah I think the biggest
advice is just don't do bits in between
comics you can have a little aside and
stuff like that but it's so obvious when
comics trying to do bits in the eyes you
know almost knit I never seen it do well
I've never seen a comic go up or Huss go
up and do the three-minute bit in
between it cut in between cons and see
it do well sometimes you know people act
like sometimes a headline might ask you
oh go up and do some time stuff like
that does or exceptions but otherwise
just keep the momentum of the show going
your job is to get up there get their
attention and then keep introducing
people and keeping people up they call
that hosts lining yeah oh sorry yeah
yeah yeah Hosting is so great I love it
because the pressure is off to be funny
it really is just about establishing a
connection with the audience so that's
why I always recommend comics to host
the show just that value of learning how
to connect with an audience yeah and if
you could connect them and be funny it's
that much it makes you that much better
if you can't if you can be if you can be
hosting a show and get a big laugh
within the first minute to like you're
doing well you know
and set up the show for everyone else is
it kind of builds it builds the
expectations always gonna be a good show
because the host was funny you know
right right dude this has been amazing
oh yeah you dropped all of them is there
anything you think we overlooked that
comics need to know about again I think
it's just you know there's no everyone
has a different path so what I might be
successful someone else might not be
success for you but you also can't allow
someone else success to take away from
your own you know everyone's doing
differently everyone has a different
path and you might sue people might be
doing the same exact thing and someone
you know it's not gonna work out for
both parties so I think you just gotta
be appreciative of this like the fact
that we're able to do this mmm that
people might sometimes pay to come see
us just talk essentially you know to
tell people you know to just go up and
talk about ourselves like the fact that
we can do that on a nightly basis is
kind of exceptional so I think just yeah
be super you know be let's say super
humble but but kind of be appreciative
of what it is yeah yeah yeah bring a
tear to my eye
yeah mayor of comedy spitting game and
it took me years to develop that mindset
but I tell you comics the sooner you can
develop that mindset the quicker you're
gonna find success because then you will
figure out what your success is exactly
not so worried about what everyone else
is success yes it constantly changes too
you know hmm and I think then I think
you know I I've definitely you know see
it's especially weird now ten years in
because I have so many people who in
those ten years either they start at the
same time as me or shortly after me and
now I see like I'm on commercial as a
late-night spot or a chorus behind the
daily show so I kind of like it
sometimes it just a little off-putting
but oh wow that person's doing this well
I might not doing that but I must like
oh why I got to do this you know so like
it's again it's different for everyone
and you know it's definitely a hustle to
it and you definitely work for it no
matter what you want to do you have to
work hard for and everyone you see who
does succeed there's a good chance that
they worked very hard to be that point
it wasn't given to them they worked as
hard as they possibly could to get where
they are and the only way you can do
that is by doing the same work hard yeah
you put the time in you know it's a job
yeah it's a job yeah
well alright hot breath verse we've done
it yeah yet another one here with no
puede so that number is this this will
be we're in the 170s 35 - 175 - 170
something yeah yeah yeah so it's it's
been great to see the ark the when we
interviewed you the first time it was
more like I'm kind of doing these things
here and there and now it's like oh I
have a production business because like
before one-up wasn't even like a an
established like LLC yet yeah yeah now
it was a full fledge like business yeah
now yeah it's funny cuz now I you know
within the show I write comics checks
that have one of the communist yeah so
it's like I had I had a headliner
recently and you know and he's you know
after the show he's talking about the
comics and now I go hey it was oka let's
go talk shop it was it was almost in
hiding and so were walking back to the
you know the green room I was like you
know that phrase it's like an instance
like superhero movies it's like if you
don't die the hero you become the
villain every time I write a check to
someone I feel like I'm becoming the
villain yeah look at they coat the coast
I get to be the cosine the clothes I
think the closer I get to be like a
comedy club owner I'm like oh no I'm
like becoming the man you know and in a
way that I didn't say envision myself
becoming but I think it's it but I think
is it's it's a cool it's a course it's
been cool and I really appreciate it so
do you want to have your own club one
day I don't know I'm torn you know I
think part me yes but part of me likes
you know the idea of that can show up to
a venue and they have like everything I
needed you know not having to worry
about paying rent and all that stuff
okay and liquor licenses and stuff like
that I think I think I would I think one
day I like - yeah yeah that'll be on the
next one yeah the comedy club that Joe
had has been yeah
so if you could for the hot breath
averse could you could you look into the
camera and let comedians know why they
should listen to hot breath uh I think
um well I'm gonna give a shout shout out
to my buddy Carter he's out in Arkansas
and he he hit me up one day and asked me
if I knew who you were because he's like
I love his podcast
he said he's up he's the guy who started
you can use array he's actually a radio
DJ who started doing comedy he loves his
podcast because
it's insight into different perspectives
on comedy mmm so I think that's why she
listed as you can listen different
people when I see I've seen who you've
had on the show and you've had different
people who have had success in multiple
aspects to get that kind of like their
perspective so and now it might be back
in like a hundred episodes or so so yeah
right I have these I have notebooks now
I'm selling notebooks okay and Carter
actually bought one and filmed and
unboxing up oh nice put it on YouTube
look at school I was like show my wife I
was like hey honey we made it yeah
that's awesome well thanks for doing
this man oh yeah thanks for having me
thrilled I I could not be happier for
the success you've had it's cool to be
in the game now and starting to see the
arc of people's careers like you said we
see people go from open mics to the
daily show but then also open mics to
prison like yeah or open mics to now
building their own platforms like you
and I are doing no dude I'm so happy for
you
and I'm happy that you we're watching
this or listening to this hot breath
averse so please if you did find this
valuable like Carter did reach out to
Joe let him know how much you enjoyed
this episode
word of mouth like Joe said is gonna be
the best way to share this so if you
reach out to Joe he's gonna be more
likely to tell other people about the
episode and reaching out to other comics
the word of mouth is our most powerful
tool here so tell other comics at your
open mikes or if you're out a weekend
show or if you got a comedy club and you
meet the headliner let him know about
this podcast anybody that you know that
is in the comedy game just let them know
that this is a tool here for them to use
they can also go to our website hot
breath podcast com there's links to be
able to get the water here there's merch
there's also other ways to just read our
blogs or get other additional content
also rating and reviewing and
subscribing is always very valuable here
in the hot breath averse but overall
just keep watching keep listening keep
supporting I have to thank my wife at
the end of all these of course she
should
she made the theme song so every episode
at the end I've been like alright thank
you honey
she even asked me to do it but now it's
become like just a tradition it's funny
but otherwise there's only one thing
left to do
that is inhale a hot bread thanks guys
have a good day night evening bye go
produce a show yeah get to work
big entitled do something
[Music]